[Music]
BAM
we're in Zombieland and we love it you
guys wanted to know more about the cast
of the Disney Channel Original Movies
zombies and we've got you covered
subscribe to the things and give us a
thumbs up if you love zombies do you
want to be a DIY expert check out our
friends at crafty hackers they have the
best hacks crafts and everything DIY
watch their videos for the best
household tricks DIY decor and fun
recipes if you love making crafts with
your friends or just trying new things
they have everything you're looking for
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any awesome hacks and crafts
fainting goat obsessions in an interview
on Radio Disney Kylee Russell who plays
the justice-seeking character Eliza
admits to having an odd obsession with
cows and fainting goats she says she can
watch videos of goats fainting for hours
we didn't even know that was a thing
until we saw it for ourselves apparently
there is a certain breed of goat whose
muscles seized up when they get startled
causing them to fall over there are tons
of videos out there of people scaring
goats to make them go step and fall down
don't worry experts say it doesn't hurt
Kylie says she thinks these goats are
super cute that is so random Kylie to
work it forever did you know that Trevor
Flanagan Tordjman who plays the role of
Bucky in zombies is a master at the fine
art of twerking he just released a
pretty rad video on his YouTube channel
of him and his crew dancing all over the
globe to the song pump it our second
favorite part of the video is when he
tap dances with a mime in front of the
Eiffel Tower in France our first
favorite part the booty shaking not only
can Trevor twerk and tap dance he can
tumble dance hip hop breakdown and burp
UNK man seriously he reminds us of a
young Gene Kelly except for the whole
twerking part river dancer meg Donnelly
who plays Addison in the film revealed
that she took Irish step-dancing classes
when she was 6 years old she seemed like
she would be pretty good in river dance
this made us curious so we dug a little
deeper into this Disney stars past we
uncovered a video of an adorable 12 year
old Meg belting out a teen at Annie's
Playhouse in Morristown New Jersey even
back then this girl had some pipes
singing girl all that and Irish dancing
skills too
snowonder Disney cast her in the lead
role of zombies with a voice like that
she probably came out of the womb
singing twins did you know that Carla
Jeffery who plays the bubbly Bri in the
movie has a twin brother who is also a
Disney star Carla's brother Carlin
Jeffery plays the role of Cameron parks
in Disney Channel's ant farm
he is also pursuing a career in music
Carlin is a rapper who goes by Lil C
note in an interview with Radio Disney
Carla shared that she and her twin
brother are going to be starting their
own acting classes these two probably
have a lot to teach up-and-coming actors
and actresses about the crap would you
like to have pearl and Karlin as your
acting teachers you auditioned how many
times milo mannheim who plays the role
of sad revealed that he had to audition
a total of eleven times for his role in
zombies 11 time Wow Milo said he was
spotted by a casting agent when he
performed in one of the many musicals he
offended will tell you more about that a
little later
according to Milo he had to send taped
auditions as well as do in-person
auditions at a casting office and
chemistry tests with his co-star meg
Donnelly luckily it all paid off and he
was finally cast as the lead role of
Zedd in this hit Disney Channel Original
Movie photo with Zac Efron in an
interview at the launch of zombies Kylie
Russell who plays the role of Eliza
revealed something pretty interesting
apparently kylie is buddies with Zac
Efron okay they may not be best friends
but she said they did play uno together
one time apparently the two Disney stars
were staying at the same hotel in
Toronto while Kylie was filming jump in
Zack was there at the same time filming
hairspray the two played uno together
she was only nine but she remembers it
fondly so who won the match between
Kylie exacts a game night with Zac Efron
that makes Kylie the winner for sure
keep an eye on this backup dancer are
any of you guys descendants and
descendants two fans if you are you may
know that Meghan Trainor no not that one
this one was a dancer and Korra's
performer in both films she is listed as
a Seabrook dancer in zombies but this
fabulous dancer has appeared on a ton of
music videos and live performances hey
Kelly Clarkson and is that hurt Trevor
Flannigan Tordjman pump it video this
lady has got some boobs told me a matter
of time before she makes her way into
the spotlight
she has already captured the heart of a
particular descendants star apparently
she's in a relationship with boo boost
all righty then we all know Milo Manheim
is ridiculously talented seriously is
there anything this guy can't do he did
admit that he is not the best dancer in
zombies but we disagree uh hello have
you seen him in the song BAM we did find
out that Milo has another interesting
hidden talent he does an awesome
impression of Jim Carrey apparently he
is one of Carey's biggest fans
he said he's watched The Truman Show
like a hundred times we think Milo has
the same charismatic nature as his idol
definitely nailed it when he
impersonates in as Ace Ventura don't you
think Oh righty then
full house co-star Kingston Foster plays
s little sister Zoe but it's not our
first role if you're a fan of fuller
house you'll recognize Kingston as Joan
Gladstone one of Joey's mischievous
daughters if the show Kingston's
character gets into Ramona gibbler's
makeup and mocks her Tina sister go on
terrorizing the house it looks like
Kingston is good at playing bad girls it
was fun to watch her and pull her house
but we prefer the green haired gray
skins character she plays in zombie it's
no offense fuller house Kingston is on a
roll she's already got some major
credits under her belt way to go little
star multi-lingual published author
Emilia McCarthy who plays lacy and
zombies is so fun to watch as the mean
girl in the film but that's not all
there is to this Disney star did you
know that Emilia is fluent in English
French and Spanish yes we see Emilia has
revealed that she is of Mexican and
Canadian descent
here's another surprising fact we found
with her dad's help Emilia had a book
published at the age of 8 it was called
baby's wish and it was about a dream she
had in the book the baby is in the womb
wondering what her parents will be like
that's pretty impressive for an
eight-year-old surfer girl you all know
Meg Donnelly Madison in the sunny town
of Seabrook yes she can sing she can
dance she can act but did you know she's
a surfer girl too in an interview with
Just Jared Meg talked about her love for
surfing and scuba diving she said that
scuba diving is one of her favorite
thing in fact Meg is this close to
getting her scuba license it's on her
to-do list she also shared her love for
hiking in the California mountains she's
really into the view from the
top with all of her talent she'll
probably be on top for quite some time
one-man band James Godfrey plays the
character Bonzo who can only speak
zombie well he may not be able to speak
English in the film he can actually play
a lot of instruments in real life at
least 32 instruments to be exact that's
enough to start a one-man band well he
seems to be naturally gifted at music he
admits he's not so hot at stand-up
comedy
he said he once did a comedy show and
only one person showed up in the
audience but what's crazy awesome is
that one person eventually became his
wife
Wow you never know who you're going to
meet at a comedy show rent so Milo
Manheim or Zed and zombie town is no
stranger to musicals in fact he is said
to have performed in at least 15 stage
musicals
that's impressive we found a clip of one
of his musical performances in this show
rent in this video we see him performing
with Mimi in number like my candle and
just like that we now a 525,600 reasons
to love Milo Manheim this guy is no
stranger to Hollywood
his mom is Emmy and Golden Globe Award
winner Camryn Manheim he grew up on the
set of the practiced and ghost whisperer
I guess you could say talent is in his
blood Emilia McCarthy played Elle
Fanning little sister do you think that
meet girl Lacey played by Emilia
McCarthy looks like Elle Fanning well
director Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
certainly thought so he hired Emilia to
play Elle Fanning sister alongside
Hollywood legends Cate Blanchett and
Brad Pitt who played their parents not a
bad gig for eight-year-old Emilia though
she told caleb mix she would really love
to start a movie with Charlize Theron
and Michelle Williams she said she would
also like to act in a movie where she
plays Amanda Seyfried sister she says
people tell her all the time that she
had a man to look alike we've had
tickets to that movie for sure
watersports and traveling the world
lovely Kingston foster or Zoe if you're
a zombie is a girl of many interests and
skills in an interview with Just Jared
she revealed that she has been
parasailing before that's something many
adults are scared to try she has also
been snorkeling which she admitted was
scary for at first some other fun facts
about Kingston are that she has been to
Mexico Canada and the Dominican Republic
and she loves to bake cookies and
blueberry muffins can you guess what
this young starlets middle name is if
you guessed Muse you are correct
what a cool middle name Kingston you
parents sure knew what they were doing
zombie makeup attorney these
good-looking Disney stars into zombies
was not an easy feat in an interview
with Seventeen magazine
Milo Manheim said his makeup took longer
than all the human characters makeup
sessions combined he said on average his
makeup routine took an hour and a half
to two hours every morning the zombie
actors had to be in the makeup chair as
early as 4:00 a.m. and that makeup was
not easy to remove Milo said taking it
off took about 45 minutes he said he
used shaving cream to get it off Kylie
agrees she said the makeup was sticky
and hard to remove her secret weapon for
taking it off
coconut oil zombie bounce you might be
wondering how the zombies house was able
to bounce their bodies off the ground
like they did in the musical number BAM
the film's choreographer Christopher
Scott revealed in an interview with
Billboard magazine that they use a taut
trampoline to allow the cast to bounce
and clip high into the air there's a
thing called an air tracks it's
basically like a giant air mattress what
made all those cigs Amba moves possible
the director Paco and wanted to make a
zombie scene superhumans and this trick
really took it to the next level
Milo loved jumping as high as he could
and bouncing off his back the lemonade
stand did you know that Milo man I've
raised money for President Obama's
campaign it's true
Milo told the daily shuffle he once had
a lemonade stand that was so successful
he was invited to President Obama's
inauguration our question is how much
money did Milo raise in order to be
invited to the inauguration did you guys
know Milo was into politics and social
justice according to his bio for the
past six years Milan has been involved
in Robert Kennedy Jr's Waterkeeper
Alliance which is a nonprofit
organization dedicated to fighting for
every community's right to drinkable
fishable swimmable water he even
interviewed Robert Kennedy jr. on CBS
about the environment bags googly eyes
and Milly rock skills we are going to
let you in on a secret hidden talent Meg
Donnelly has sure this zombies actors
can sing dance and act but did you know
she can also do this with her eyes how
is she still gorgeous when she's making
her eyes cross legs up is so amazingly
weird another fun fact about Maggie is
that her go-to dance move is the Billy
Rock she posted this video on her
Instagram page doing the Milly rock to
Tupac I get around in the
makeup chair unset she's definitely got
some Millie rock down and her makeup
artist got some sweet moves too
Milo is crushed do you guys want to know
who Milo's secret crushes will give you
a hint
she was also at Disney star once if you
guessed Selena Gomez you win the
Internet today
Milo confessed to Disney Channel that he
loves crushing on Selena Gomez but he's
probably not going to ask her out
anytime soon
that's because he's already got a
girlfriend this zombies star is also
starring in a production of Chicago
alongside his current girlfriend
Holliday Kregel with the name like
Holliday this girl got to be fun to hang
out with we learned that in addition to
being an actress and singer she is also
a champion equestrian giddyup and that's
all of the 20 things you didn't know
about the cast of zombies thanks for
watching our video here on the things
see you around
[Music]